In the week that we are set to get GPT5,
it might be easy to miss this
announcement of Google Deep Minds Genie
3. To cut a long story short, it makes
the world playable. Start with an image,
which could be one of your photos, and
then enter that world and modify it with
prompts. By entering, I mean you can
move around, take actions that last and
stay in that world, and basically go
wild. I was given early access to the
presentation of Genie3 and got to ask
the makers a question, but I'm going to
be honest. Genie 3 is designed and
marketed to allow AI agents to act out
scenarios and self-improve at taking
actions. That's the theory for me. And
let me know if you agree. It will be
used much more for gamifying all of
reality and your imagination. If you
have been following the channel for just
a little bit, you know that I
interviewed a senior researcher on Genie
2, Tim Rockshaw here and on my Patreon.
And at the time, we learned that Genie 2
would quote scale gracefully with more
compute. Well, it did. And now we get
real-time interaction in 720p 24 frames
pers. If that's jargon to you, it means
you can click some buttons and things
happen at the exact same time on screen
at fairly high resolution. Now, in a
couple of minutes, I'm going to show you
the full intro, which is about 130
seconds, I think, which is unusual for
this channel. I don't normally show
clips that long, but it does showcase
Genie 3 really quite well. First though,
just a few thoughts from me. Jack Parker
Holder, the lead author of Genie3, told
me and a bunch of journalists, that the
goal behind it was to have a move 37
moment for embodied AI, as in for
robots, not just for computers that play
games. A move 37 moment is a high bar,
as any of you who have watched the Alph
Go documentary know, but think of it as
a novel breakthrough that goes beyond
the human data. In other words, we just
don't have enough data to train robots
reliably given the innumerable scenarios
in which they'll be placed. If we can
simulate all worlds, then we might get
novel breakthroughs for those robots.
Get them to do things essentially that
we couldn't have even trained them to
do. In the presentation, I pushed back
though with the question that if these
worlds suffer from physics inaccuracies,
and they do, how would such agents ever
be fully reliable? Both lead authors
agreed that's a real issue, but then
raised something that got me thinking.
They said that yes, while you can't
guarantee reliability, you can
demonstrate unreliability. Think about
it. If an agent goes off the rails in
simulation, then it's also liable to do
so in the real world. In a way, then I
think both of these points still stand.
I think we can't guarantee reliability
with simulators like Genie 3, but we can
help find unreliability. Anyway, what
you're probably thinking, and I
definitely was, was that we should just
be honest with ourselves. Everyone is
going to want to upload a still from
their favorite game, Life event,
celebrity, or what have you, and
basically interact with it, jump around,
paint a wall, and just get silly. And
even that is probably phrasing things
somewhat maturely, which is probably why
this is currently still a research
preview, meaning you can't get your
hands on it. Google were pretty evasive
about timing for a general release, not
even a hint of a date. However, if that
disappoints you, I am old enough to
remember that that same I guess not for
general release safety issues kind of
thing was true of Imagine 1, the very
basic image generator from Google.
Basically not fit for public release.
But as of today, we have Imagine 4 out
in public, far improved, and even
available on the API so developers can
incorporate it into their apps.
translated Genie 4 might be available to
you to play with sooner than you think.
Okay, but what about that incredible
memory where you could paint a wall, for
example, look around, come back, and the
paint is still there. Let's just take a
moment and say, Google, that is pretty
impressive. Well done. But the memory
within these worlds is measured in
minutes, not hours. So, if you are
thinking of making a friend in one of
these worlds, building a house together,
and living in it to escape the real
world and its current self- emulation,
that won't quite work. As it currently
stands, by the time you return to the
house the next day, it will be
completely reimagined. And Google told
me of four other caveats. I think they
are pretty telling about the future of
simulation. So, let's go through them.
First, while the most common actions are
performable, as you'd find in games,
like moving around and jumping, you
can't currently perform complex actions.
Next, and this thought literally just
came to me, but it's a bit like a dream
in that the next caveat is that you
can't talk to other characters. Maybe
that's just me, but in your dreams, do
you speak to other people? Definitely
not complex conversations. Anyway, they
said to me, accurately modeling complex
interactions between multiple
independent agents is still an ongoing
research challenge. Third, as you would
expect, we can't expect accurate
representation of realworld locations.
The sheer imaginative scope of these
worlds are also somewhat their downfall
in that lifelike fidelity is not their
priority. That bleeds into the fourth
caveat they gave me, which is text
rendering. Don't expect highfidelity
text rendering. It can happen if you add
it to your prompt. It's just not built
into the environment. Now, funnily
enough, I think it was a Guardian or New
York Times journalist asked actually
about whether this is a replacement for
something like Omniverse or Unreal
Engine. Google wouldn't say that, but
they did say that hard coding the
complexity of the real world is
intractable. So, that's why we might
need simulations like the Genie series.
I know quite a few game developers watch
the channel, so do chip in with your
thoughts on this versus Unreal Engine.
And I would add there's a hybrid
approach which I saw recently in a TED
talk from a guy from Roblox. I forget
his name and his rank, but the idea was
that you could prompt a model to
directly code new parts of the
environment. The full six-minute talk is
linked in the description. But this
feels to me like it would be slightly
more predictable perhaps, but maybe less
scalable because with the Genie series,
you could scale it with billions of
hours of video from YouTube, not so much
with hard-coded assets. Which approach
will win out? I actually don't know. So,
let me know what you think. Now, enough
buildup. There is no paper to go
through. I was going to release this
video at 3 p.m. when the embargo lifted,
but I thought maybe they're going to
give us a paper. So, let's hold back.
No, there was no paper. So, here is the
around 2-minute demo that I promised,
albeit slightly later than I said I
would give it.
What you're seeing are not games or
videos. They're worlds.
Each one of these is an interactive
environment generated by Genie 3, a new
frontier for world models. With Genie3,
you can use natural language to generate
a variety of worlds and explore them
interactively, all with a single text
prompt.
[Music]
Let's see what it's like to spend some
time in a world.
Genie 3 has real-time interactivity,
meaning that the environment reacts to
your movements and actions. You're not
walking through a pre-built simulation.
Everything you see here is being
generated live as you explore it. And
Genie 3 has world memory. That's why
environments like this one stay
consistent.
World memory even carries over into your
actions.
For example, when I'm painting on this
wall, my actions persist.
[Applause]
I can look away and generate other parts
of the world, but when I look back, the
actions I took are still there.
And Genie3 enables promptable events, so
you can add new events into your world
on the fly. something like another
person
or transportation
or even something totally unexpected.
You can use Genie to explore real world
physics and movement and all kinds of
unique environments.
You can generate worlds with distinct
geographies, historical settings,
fictional environments, and even other
characters. We're excited to see how
Genie 3 can be used for next generation
gaming and entertainment. And that's
just the beginning. Worlds could help
with embodied research, training robotic
agents before working in the real world,
or simulating dangerous scenarios for
disaster preparedness and emergency
training.
World models can open new pathways for
learning, agriculture,
manufacturing, and more.
We're excited to see how Genie 3's world
simulation can benefit research around
the world.
Trying to game out the impact of
technologies like Genie on jobs is just
too complex for me at the moment. But
there are real world jobs you can apply
to via the sponsors of today's video,
80,000 hours. If you somewhat helpfully
use my link in the description, then
you'll go to their job board, which you
can see, and these are all real jobs
related to AI. Well, I think the
majority relate to AI, but either way,
the jobs are sourced from around the
world. Now, you could say, why even
cover Genie 3? And don't worry, I will
be touching on Gemini Deepthink on the
main channel, which is also from Google
Deep Mind, soon enough. And my early
review of that tool is on Patreon. But
it just feels inevitable to me that
people will initially want their games
to be infinitely playable. Think a map
size bigger than GTA 7. As expectations
continue to rise, they'll want their
entertainment to be interactive. say
prompting Netflix to add their own face
into Squid Game US edition. And it will
just never stop. It will then be in VR
in 16K. You'll be able to speak to other
agents or let's just call them bots. The
other characters in the simulated worlds
will be pretty intelligent. They
probably won't just keep walking into
walls. You can like chat with them about
Sophocles. Some people may even need to
watch their step less they fall into
these infinite worlds. Others will dive
in headlong. But the step up in
resolution and memory and the commitment
from Google to incorporate this into
their march to AGI seems noteworthy.
These worlds then will be born one way
or another. But the question for me is
whether a fully imagined simulation is
the way or instead my bet which is
something more like Isaac Lab from
Nvidia simulated but also programmable
and so repeatable. Soon enough many
worlds are about to get crazy not just
the real one. Thank you so much for
watching to the end. I look forward to
covering GPT5 with you guys this week
almost certainly. Have a wonderful